[Musique]
j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire d'un petit garçon que j'ai
bien connu le père de son père son
grand-père paternel donc était tunisiens
arrivés en france comme tant d'autres
dans les années 50 comme ouvrier la mère
de son père était bretonne de brest s'il
vous plaît ouvrière elle aussi côté
maternel le père de sa mère était
guadeloupéen d'origine anglaise noir
officiers mariniers et océanographes la
mère de sa mère sa mamie chéri était
guadeloupéen elle aussi noire elle aussi
mais d'origine amérindienne
pourquoi je vous raconte cette histoire
bien je vous la raconte parce qu'elle
résume bien notre histoire de france
une histoire où se côtoient prolétaires
et bourgeois esclaves et esclavagiste
colonisés et colonisateur pas facile de
savoir qui on est avec une telle
généalogie pas facile non plus de se
construire une identité sereine dans nos
sociétés postcoloniales
le garçon dont je vous parle avait un
petit frère même père même mère même
éducation
l'aîné a fait de brillantes études et a
pu choisir sa vie notamment
professionnelle le second lui a quitté
l'école à 16 ans sans qualification sans
diplôme sans horizon et
il a mis un certain nombre d'années
avant de finalement trouver sa place à
travers le théâtre l'un était-il plus
intelligent que l'autre évidemment non
simplement la maîtrise est des codes
scolaire l'autre pas l'un pouvait
recevoir une forme de reconnaissance du
système l'autre pas pourtant l'essentiel
reliait ses deux frères l'essentiel
c'était d'abord une même interrogation
sur leur identité
une même interrogation sur leur place
dans la société
un même besoin de sens et aussi un même
besoin de se sentir utile
les deux enfants dont je vous parlais
c'était mon frère et moi il ya
maintenant près de dix ans nous sommes
lancés dans la création d'une petite
association à vocation culturelle les
cités d'or et à notre grande surprise
nous nous sommes rendu compte que les
personnes avec lesquelles nous
travaillons les participants aux
ateliers partageaient les mêmes
problématiques que les nôtres la même
interrogation sur leur identité
la même interrogation sur leur place
dans la société
le même besoin de sens le même besoin de
se sentir utile et d'être reconnus comme
tels
tous ou presque avait eu des parcours
assez accidenté se sentait démunis en
tant que personne et désarmé en tant que
citoyen d'où une question qui s'est
imposé à tous et à laquelle nous avons
souhaité répondre tous ensemble cette
question c'est la suivante
de quoi est ce qu'on a besoin quel que
soit son âge
quelle que soit sa situation pour
devenir acteur acteur de sa vie acteurs
de la société
et finalement nous y avons répondu
essayer en tout cas et nous avons
identifié ensemble cinq piliers humains
cinq ensembles de savoir de savoir faire
et de savoir être dont nous avons tous
besoin
vous donnez votre langue au chat ou pas
oui ou non
bon alors j'y vais premier pilier
argumenté un point de vue est entrée
dans un débat bref convaincre sans
manipuler ni être manipulé deuxième
qu'il y ait trouvé l'info échappé à
l'intox troisième pilier tisser du lien
cultiver nos relations humaines
quatrième pilier être en paix avec
soi-même cultiver suffisamment de
confiance en soi et de conscience de soi
dernier pilier enfin comprendre le
fonctionnement du monde dans lequel
envie je résume s'exprimer
s'informer tisser du lien
s'accepter comprendre son environnement
cinq piliers qu'on explore au quotidien
à travers ce qu'on appelait les école
buissonnière alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une école buissonnière mais école
buissonnière c'est d'abord une aventure
collective pendant plusieurs mois une
dizaine de participants vont apprendre à
se connaître partager des outils de vie
mené ensemble des projets collectifs
réfléchir évidemment leur rôle de
citoyen et rencontrer des personnalités
inspirantes
par exemple une ministre de la justice
en plein débat sur le mariage pour tous
par exemple un réalisateur de dessins
animés absolument passionné qui a dû
attendre tenez vous bien 50 ans et
quelques brouettes et manger beaucoup de
pain rassis avant de rencontrer une
gloire planétaire avec le dessin animé
kirikou
je pourrais vous parler aussi
d'intellectuels de sportifs
d'entrepreneurs tout ça pour vous dire
qu'on est bien dans une aventure
individuelle mais on est aussi dans une
aventure pardon une aventure collective
mais aussi une aventure individuelle
cette aventure individuelle elle va
d'abord consister à s'interroger sur son
rapport à soi suis-je authentique
y at-il dans mon quotidien adéquation
entre mes pensées mes paroles et mes
actes mais on peut être parfaitement
authentique et être un parfait
pensé comme un parler comme un
agir comme un et être
parfaitement alignés
d'où la nécessité de s'interroger sur
son rapport aux autres suis-je juste
juste au sens de la justice de
l'asymétrie de la réciprocité
mais juste aussi au sens de la justesse
est-ce que je suis bien ajustés aux
personnes avec lesquelles j'interagis
dans mon quotidien
mais on peut être parfaitement justes et
être parfaitement perdu d'où la
nécessité de s'interroger sur son
rapport au monde à la totalité du réel
suis-je vrai qu'elle sans showdown à la
vie en général et à ma vie en
particulier quel sens donner à la
société
quel sens donner à l'histoire face
question cette aventure individuelle
elle va consister aussi pour les
participants à se réapproprier une
identité et enfin à rencontrer des
personnes qui vivent sur une autre
planète que la mienne quelques exemples
véridique
un ado avec une jeune grand mère de 58
ans un ancien sdf avec une doctorante en
droit international
un croyant convaincu avec un alt et
militant depuis des années je côtoie ces
personnes et ces personnes elle m'invite
évidemment à réfléchir un certain nombre
de choses
la première chose c'est que j'ai appris
auprès d'elles comme j'ai appris auprès
de mon petit frère que les gens ont
autant besoin de sens qu'ils ont besoin
de pain et d'eau le sens c'est d'abord
une direction vers laquelle tourné son
regard et ses efforts sous peine de
tâtonner en aveugle dans l'existence le
sens c'est aussi la signification que
chacun va donner à cette direction et
enfin le sens c'est la capacité pour
chacun à incarner tout cela dans son
quotidien dans la singularité de sa vie
mais ce sens aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on
le trouve à l'école au boulot dans le
débat public
je vous laisse répondre à cette question
ces personnes le fait de les côtoyer
ça m'a aussi amené à m'interroger sur la
notion d'insertion deux choses
l'insertion se sont d'abord des
personnes des personnes souvent
remarquables qui font un boulot
nécessaire difficile et bien mal
reconnus par la société
mais l'insertion c'est aussi un système
c'est aussi une logique c'est aussi une
philosophie
les personnes doivent être salué et
remercié pour le travail qu'elles font
au quotidien
le système en revanche mérite sans doute
d'être ré interroger
arrêtons nous un instant sur le terme
même d'insertion l'individu est un petit
rouage un petit boulon qui doit
s'insérer dans une méga machine qui le
dépasse et qui lui donne sa raison
d'être
l'individu peut-il transformer cette
machine
franchement est ce que vous auriez idée
de poser une telle question une vie soir
un boulon mais au delà du mot à quoi ça
rime de faire aujourd'hui de l'insertion
professionnelle la condition de
l'insertion sociale dans une période de
chômage de masse bref mon sentiment
c'est que ce système il est voué à
l'échec
s'ils ne s'attaquent pas frontalement à
une question fondamentale
cette question c'est l'enracinement des
personnes le sentiment d'appartenance
la participation à une communauté
humaine c'est pas une affaire d'abord
économique ou matériel c'est d'abord une
affaire de sens est enracinement
l'enracinement qu'est ce que c'est
l'enracinement c'est d'abord cette
capacité à s'inscrire dans l'histoire
avec un grand h
et dans toutes ces petites histoires qui
nous précèdent l'enracinement c'est la
fierté de prolonger des cours bas qui
ont été menés avant moi et pour moi peu
importe d'ailleurs que ces combats se
sont soldées par des victoires ou par
des défaites
l'enracinement c'est pouvoir se dire je
suis l'humanité je suis la société pas
par mégalomanie pathologique
évidemment que l'humanité la société ne
se résume pas ma petite personne
en revanche à travers chacun de mes
choix
même les plus insignifiants à travers
moi l'humanité son visage le visage la
société se redessine à travers chacun de
mes choix
vous allez me dire c'est bien joli tout
ça mais on a besoin de quoi pour
s'enraciner
je vous répondrai qu'on a besoin de
quelque chose qui est aussi solide et
aussi fragile car auch et de souffle
cette chose c'est la reconnaissance la
reconnaissance ses avoirs étaient ou
être aimé être reconnus en chair et en
os parce que c'est toi parce que c'est
moi aucune autre raison de nouveau sans
quoi il n'y a ni confiance en soi ni
confiance en l'autre la reconnaissance
c'est la certitude de disposer des mêmes
droits et des mêmes devoirs que les
autres sans quoi il n'y a ni respect de
soi ni respect des autres la
reconnaissance c'est tout bête
c'est le fait de se sentir utile d'avoir
le sentiment de contribuer même
modestement à l'aventuré collective sans
quoi il ne peut y avoir ni estime de soi
ce qui a pendant de très nombreuses
années manque à mon petit frère ni
sentiment de participation à la société
mon dernier mot ne sera pas une
conclusion est plutôt une ouverture et
cette ouverture elle tient en un mot
réconciliation
nous sommes un grand pays nous faisons
face aujourd'hui à des défis
extraordinaires et mon rêve mon voeu mon
combat aussi c'est que tous ensemble
avec les cités d'or et avec tant
d'autres nous puissions contribuer à une
vaste politique de réconciliation en
france pour nous réconcilier entre nous
entre français d'origines de cultures de
convictions différentes
non pas pour penser dans le même sens
parce que ce serait absurde mais pour
essayer de pousser dans le même sens
pour nous réconcilier avec nous même et
essayer de dépasser les contradictions
qui nous déchire au quotidien entre le
producteur et le consommateur le citoyen
l'habitant de la planète qui cohabitent
en chacun d'entre nous pour nous
réconcilier enfin avec le monde un monde
où ne l'oublions pas la blessure
coloniale est encore ouverte et où la
planète est à bout de souffle
bref laissons l'insertion pour les
boulons et cultivant leurs racines mans
pour les gens et comme dirait l'autre
ce n'est pas parce que les choses sont
impossibles que nous nous entreprenons
pas c'est parce que nous entreprenons
pas qu'elles paraissent impossibles
je vous remercie